thank you kendall march is colorectal
cancer awareness month so
i spoke to a southwest medical doctor to
learn more here's our conversation
of course we've got a lot to talk about
i know you are a gastroenterologist
please define that for everybody what do
you do so
i am a stomach and colon doctor
basically
i uh deal with intestinal diseases
like ulcers colon cancers
um you know anything that has to do with
the gi tract
march is colorectal cancer awareness
month so this is a great time to
educate everybody on the statistics
right
correct colorectal cancer is the third
most common diagnosed cancer
in the united states and 147 000 people
can be diagnosed with cancer in one year
and 50
53 000 people can die of colorectal
cancer
every year so it's definitely
a cancer that that can be prevented
um and that's what we're here to do
absolutely prevention is key here so
what should people
look for you know when they're when
they're trying to self-diagnose
mainly people should look for
common symptoms would be bleeding so
blood in your stool or blood in the
toilet bowl
change in your bowel habits if they
become thinner or smaller or you start
having diarrhea
abdominal pain weight loss that's
unexplained
so colonoscopy is what we use to prevent
colon cancer and it's a procedure that i
do
that's done as an outpatient to look for
either polyps
which are lesions in the colon that can
turn into cancer if not removed
or actual colon cancer so if i see a
polyp i would remove it and
prevent that person from getting colon
cancer other screening tests would be uh
two stool tests that we have currently
one is the fit test
uh which is done at home and it looks
for
blood in the stool microscopic blood
meaning blood that you might not be able
to see
and so that's one of the tests and then
the most recent test that we have is
called the cola guard test which is
actually a stool test that looks for
cancer or pre-cancerous cells
in the stool which can be seen
with large polyps or actual pulling
cancer
so if these tests are positive then you
would want to proceed with the
colonoscopy colon cancer is very
preventable
with colonoscopy or the other screening
modalities everyone over the age of
50 and actually recently has been
lowered to 45
up to 75 to 80 should be
screened regularly for colon cancer
uh because that's the only way we're
going to prevent it
well how often should people get a
colonoscopy
um so it depends um upon their family
history
[Music]
and if they've had polyps in the past
usually it's every 10 years for the
normal population but can
be up to five years if you have a family
history of colon cancer
or have a history of polyps
southwest medical has several locations
across southern nevada for more
information
call 702 702-877-5199
or just visit smalv.com las vegas now